maurice denis bonheur rêver c'est le
titre de la nouvelle exposition du musée
départemental maurice denis c'est aussi
la première qui présente la vie du
peintre dans sa ville phare saint
germain en laye cette exposition fait
écho également à l'obtention du label
maison des illustres c'est vraiment
faire ressentir aux visiteurs l'esprit
du lieu puisque on est ici dans la
dernière maison de maurice denis et la
dernière partie de l'exposition est
consacrée aux années prieuré donc on a
des représentations de la maison de
maurice données dans laquelle on se
trouve dans l'exposition l'exposition
est construite en quatre parties et
parcourt la vie de maurice denis au fil
de ces maisons dans chaque partie de
l'exposition est présentée en portrait
ou un autoportrait du peintre est ici
donc ce portrait bien connue de maurice
denis par par lacombe lacombe qui était
un des membres du groupe des nabis dont
maurice denis et l théoriciens et qui a
fait le buste de différents membres du
groupe sérusier qu'on présente dans la
première salle de l'exposition en bronze
une centaine d'oeuvres sont exposées
plusieurs proviennent des collections du
musée d'autres de collections privées
cette exposition retrace aussi
l'intimité de maurice denis on peut y
voir ses parents ses différentes maisons
et des portraits de famille comme celui
que par maurice denis en 1902 vraiment
le la femme qui a le plus été représenté
dans son oeuvre on la voit dans leur
intérieur 59 rue de mareil qui est un un
appartement juste à côté du musée on
voit mart avec trois de ses filles les
trois aînés et les trois petites est ce
qui est intéressant dans ce tableau
c'est d'abord la gamme de couleurs et
surtout l'évocation de l'intérieur de
maurice denis l'exposition occupe les
deux niveaux de présentation des salles
elle est visible jusqu'au 29 mai